now we can work on the triple integral
part of our of our problem or our proof
this right over here and so i can
rewrite that
so this is the triple integral
the triple integral
over
our region which we're assuming is a
type 1 region of the partial of r with
respect to z which you could write like
this doesn't matter partial of r with
respect to z
and al d v and we can rewrite this as we
can assume we're going to integrate with
respect to z first so i'm going to
integrate with respect to z let me do
that in another color i'm going to
integrate with respect to z first the
lower bound on z in our type 1 region
the lower bound is f1 the upper bound is
f2
so we're going to integrate from f1
f1 of x
y
to f2 of xy
f2
of
y and i'm going to integrate the partial
of r with respect to z
so let me do that in that same yellow
color partial of r with respect to z and
then i have dz and then i'll have to
integrate with respect to y and x or
with respect to x and y so it's d x d y
or d y d x i can just write that as d a
d a so what you could think of it we can
evaluate the yellow part and then we're
just going to take the double integral
over
over the x y domain so this is just
going to be over the x y domain so let
me put some brackets here or some just
to make it clear what we're going to do
so all we're doing is we're integrating
with respect to z first and we have the
bounds there well this is pretty
straightforward this is all going to be
equal to i'll write the outside first
the double integral over the domain
and i have the da
the da right over here so let me give
myself some real estate d a
well what's the anti-derivative of this
this is just r and this is just r or r
of x y z evaluated when z is f1 or when
z is f2 and from that we evaluate when z
is f1 so this is just going to be r of x
y and z and we evaluate when z is equal
to that and from that we subtract it
when z is equal to that so that's going
to be equal to so r
r of x y z valued when z is equal to
that is
r
of x
y
f 2
of x
y and from that we need to subtract
r when z is this
minus r
of
x
y
f 1
of x y
and then make sure that we got our
parentheses
we got our parentheses now this is
exactly what we saw in the last video it
is exactly that which shows that this is
exactly this
so when we assumed it was a type 1
region we got that this is exactly equal
to this you do the exact same argument
with the type 2 region to show that this
is equal to this type 3 region so this
is equal to that and you have your
divergence theorem proved and we can
consider ourselves consider ourselves
done